the presence of American troops in
Afghanistan has long been a
controversial issue on Monday Secretary
of Defense Mark ESPA and the top US
General in Afghanistan told a news
conference in Kabul the Pentagon has
been quietly reducing its troop numbers
over the last year at least 2,000 we've
reduced the authorized strength by 2,000
here so there's a constant look as a
military commander to optimize the force
here and what it's based on is you
understand the risks to the force risks
in the mission and look at it in terms
of capabilities ESPA try to reassure
allies by saying the move doesn't mean
the u.s. is backing away from its
commitment to finding a political
solution to decades of war a negotiated
political settlement among Afghans is
the best path to achieving this outcome
until that is accomplished we will
continue to pursue an aggressive
military campaign against the Taliban
and terrorist groups that continue to
conduct violence against the people of
Afghanistan also in Kabul on Monday to
meet Afghan leaders a u.s. congressional
delegation led by House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi reducing the number of foreign
troops in Afghanistan was the focal
point of the recent talks between the
u.s. and the Taliban but those talks
failed after President Trump blamed the
Taliban for a surge in violence there
has been an increase in attacks in
recent months mainly from the Taliban
and ISIL links groups adding more
pressure on local security forces
Afghans are also waiting to find out who
won last month's general election the
results have been delayed because of
technical problems both parties to the
conflict pro-government and
anti-government forces are equally
responsible for the killing of civilians
and people are really tired with the
violence and they want something
different and they know that both the
United States and the Taliban have felt
already and that's why they're looking
for another party to come in and
actually own defeat as the future of
Afghanistan remains uncertain there is
no official indication of talks resuming
with the Taliban or what the departure
US troops will mean for security in the
region Rahila Mohammed Al Jazeera